robert e lee today the min mention of
his name is enough to arouse passionate
debate in his time he was loved and
respected by both the confederate army
in the southern people
curiously following the civil war this
high admiration carried over to include
the people of the north and lee became a
cherished figure for all americans
during the war when abraham lincoln
looked at a picture of lee he remarked
that a man with such compassionate
countenance had to be a good man but the
water which he devoted is every fibre
broke him if not in spirit certainly in
body and he was only to outlive the
conflicts by five years in today's
biographic s-- we discover the man who
was robert e lee
robert e lee was born on January the
19th 1807 at Stratford Hill plantation
in Westmoreland County Virginia his
father they wealthy Virginia aristocrat
been a hero during the American
Revolution a series of bad investments
left Lighthorse Harry penniless and he
fled Virginia and his family never to
return
Lee was raised by his mother the proud
and educated woman she was to see that
her son was not to be deprived of a
proper upbringing because he was
fatherless and she made sure that he was
well educated in the arts languages and
philosophy young Robert secured an
appointment to the United States
Military Academy at West Point in 1825
and he graduated second in his class he
immediately began his career in the
United States Army
they distinguished himself in the
Mexican War when he served as a member
of staff for fellow Virginian General
Winfield Scott as a captain Lee was
responsible for several courageous
personal reconnaissance missions which
produced intelligence that led to
American victories during this period
the military had no medals for bravery
so officers were given brevet promotions
for brave deeds during warfare captain
Lee received three of these prevents
during the Mexican War - major -
Lieutenant Colonel and finally - Colonel
Scott describes Lee as the very best
soldier I ever saw in the field we
progressed through a series of military
assignments in the peacetime army and
was in command of the 1st Cavalry in
Texas at the beginning of the Civil War
Lee got caught up early in the political
turmoil that was about to engulf the
nation while he was on leave from his
position in Texas John Brown attacked
the armory at Harpers Ferry an event
that clearly set the nation on the road
to war President Buchanan called on lead
to take command of a small federal force
that would be responsible for bringing
the situation under control
Lee and the future subordinate he was
also on leave je B Stewart took command
of a small group of Marines and captured
the insurgents along with brown as the
nation began to fracture bleeb like most
of his contemporaries in the Army was
placed in a difficult situation as it
became obvious that the southern states
plan to defend themselves with arms
General Winfield Scott the aging
patriarch of the army urged Lincoln to
awefully command of the army learning of
this offer Lee struggled with the
definition of duty a word that had meant
everything to him as an officer in the
United States Army
on April the 19th 1861 after Virginia
had quit the Union robert e lee faced
the most difficult decision of his life
it kept him up all night pacing the
wooden floor of his arlington mansion
Lee's daughter Mary Curtis Lee recalls
that that night Arlington was like a
place where a death had occurred the
death in question was the end of a
brilliant military career Lee's wife
Mary later wrote my husband has wept
tears of blood over this terrible war
but as a man of honor and as a Virginian
he must follow the destiny of his state
it was the severus struggle of his life
do you resign a commission he had held
for thirty years to accept the command
would undoubtedly mean fighting against
his native Virginia and the south
something that he simply couldn't bring
himself to do resignation from the Army
was also a difficult choice to make and
as he wrestled with his decision he was
attended by the prospects of bloodshed
on either side finally he decided to
resign his commission in the army and
attempt to avoid service with either
side in the forthcoming conflict Lee
himself wrote with all my devotion to
the Union and the feeling of loyalty and
duty of an American citizen I have not
been able to make up my mind to raise my
hand against my relatives my children my
home I have therefore resigned my
commission in the army except in the
defense of my native state I hope to
never draw my sword again this statement
was to prove to be prophetic on Monday
April the 22nd 1861 Lee left his home at
Arlington never to return
within two weeks Union troops they
occupied his house Mary and their four
girls they were vagabonds of war his
three sons were soldiers in gray while
Lee was in Richmond planning the defense
of Virginia the general belief among
politicians in the south was that the
war would be short but Lee he believed
otherwise he stated if it comes to a
conflict of arms the war will last at
least four years northern politicians do
not appreciate the determination and
plaque of the south and southern
politicians do not appreciate the
numbers resources and patient
perseverance of the north both sides
forget we are all Americans I foresee
that the country will have to pass
through a terrible ordeal a necessary
expiation perhaps for our national sins
during the early days of the war it
became apparent early that the South
would fight a defensive war and that his
beloved Virginia would become the major
battlefield of that war he accepted a
commission as a commander of Virginia's
troops and was soon commissioned as a
brigadier general in the Confederate
Army he remains in relatively obscure
positions during the first year of the
war as he gains his earliest experiences
in the Civil War in the mountainous
region of western Virginia here the poor
weather combines with the political
infighting between two of Virginia's
former governors now generals resulted
in disastrous military failures for the
Confederacy Lee he was attacked in
southern newspapers as evacuating Lee
and granny Lee his hair and his new
beard turned gray
during the tension-filled mounting
campaigns Lee's next assignment it was
on the Carolinas seacoast where he was
responsible for building defenses to
prevents large-scale Union Army attacks
from the sea he placed his strong
defensive positions upstream where
shallow rivers could not be easily
navigated by the Union Navy Lee's
ability as a military engineer was
proved by the fact that his defenses
were to last for much of the war he was
also nicknamed the King of Spades
because of the construction work that he
managed his detractors however were soon
to realize their mistake in misjudging
this aggressive officer when his West
Point classmate and Joseph V Johnson was
severely wounded at the Battle of Seven
Pines in June of 1862 Lee was placed in
command of what would soon become the
legendary Army of Northern Virginia as
Union General George McClellan advanced
towards the new Confederate capital Lee
ordered his men to begin digging
defenses for Richmond giving new
credence to one of his nicknames but he
soon was to demonstrate the audacious
side of his military personality Lee
initiated the seven days campaign On
June the 25th 1862 and he had soon
pushed the Union Army from the outskirts
of Richmond by August 29th Ian dasami
we're positioned to do battle of
Manassas Virginia where he defeated the
Union Army for a second time before
invading Maryland this new commander of
the Confederate Army had completely
changed the military situation in only a
few weeks in June the entire Union Army
had been poised to attack Richmond but
by September Lee was in a position from
which he could threaten wash
in DC Lee's army fought to a stalemate
at the Battle of Antietam on September
the 17th and withdrew to the southern
side of the PATA mac in december Blee
was able to conclude the 1862 campaign
with a major victory over Ambrose
Burnside's Union forces of
Fredericksburg Virginia sending the
northern army reeling back to their
bases near Washington Lee and his heart
marching subordinate Stonewall Jackson
were able to defeat a larger Union Army
under Joseph Hooker at Chancellorsville
in the first campaign of 1863 but the
victory was costly
Jackson was fatally wounded by his own
men while conducting a personal
reconnaissance of the enemy's lines this
was actually a common feature of good
Confederate commanders they would
actually conduct their own
reconnaissance during a lull in the
battle viewed as unnecessary bravado by
some historians this was actually a key
to the successful operations of the
Confederate commanders and Lee himself
frequently undertook these hazardous
operations he returns from a personal
battlefield reconnaissance at second
Manassas with a mark on his face where a
sharp shooters bullet and grazed him
Lee's immediate reaction to the death of
his most trusted officer was that it was
God's will and the Lord would raise
someone else up to take Jackson's place
in that hope however he was mistaken Lee
would just have to do the best he could
by himself at Chancellorsville Lee
cemented his reputation as a brilliant
battlefield commander it was a battle
that seemingly on paper he could not win
outnumbered two to one
he still divided his army in half in the
face of the enemy he won the battle in
spectacular fashion and it was
undoubtedly his most famous victory the
victory at Chancellorsville cleared the
way for another Confederate invasion of
the north confusion within the Union
Army combined with the losses of the
earlier battle gave Lee the opportunity
he longed for a chance to destroy the
Union Army in a classic Napoleonic
battle that would end the Civil War this
was a high-risk operation but Lee placed
great faith in the ability of his army
of Northern Virginia and at Gettysburg
this is where he would attempt to do it
again
in June of 1863 Lee boldly moved his
army of nearly 60,000 men into union
territory his plan was to destroy as
many military posts as occurred in
Maryland and Pennsylvania while the
Union Army was forced to defend
Washington DC a key target was camp
Curtin just outside of Harrisburg
Pennsylvania this was the largest
military supply depot in the north Lee's
main aim was not to defeat the Union
Army militarily but to bring the war to
an end politically he believed that a
massive defeat in the north would
encourage people to lose faith in the
war and demanded sense however as the
Confederate forces moved north a
skirmish erupted in Gettysburg
Pennsylvania between opposing cavalry
units Lee got word of the skirmish and
was startled to be informed that a major
Union force was closing in on Gettysburg
instead of sending a cavalry
reconnaissance force to confirm the
report he sent his entire army to
mobilize this is something that history
would record as a colossal mistake they
ordered all of his forces to converge at
Cashtown a small village seven miles
from Gettysburg as these 60,000
Confederates poured in around 3,000
Union soldiers took position on
McPherson Ridge these men tried to hold
off the onslaught of rebel soldiers
until help arrived
but reinforcements were miles away in
Washington DC the Union soldiers they
were forced to withdraw south east onto
Cemetery Ridge a range of hills on the
outskirts of Gettysburg that forms the
shape of a fishhook this position
provided an extremely strong defensive
advantage Lee immediately saw the danger
in the strength of the Union position
but because of his numerical superiority
he believed that the enemy was
vulnerable however Union forces soon
arrived and strengthened their defensive
position though it was nowhere near
Lee's best campaign much of what
happened at Gettysburg was still
remarkable from a southern perspective
Lee was outnumbered and without much of
his cavalry the cavalry was used largely
for reconnaissance in order to find the
enemy and establish his size and
strength but Lee's cavalry regiments
were in the process of raiding the
entire Union Army rather than gathering
information and screening the flanks of
Lee's army he was also without his most
trusted officer General Thomas Stonewall
Jackson who had been killed at
Chancellorsville six weeks earlier still
Lee failed to adjust his strategy to the
situation on the grounds he refused to
retreat even when the situation was
clearly hopeless after three days of
terrible fighting and unprecedented
losses the Confederates were forced to
withdraw from the field and make a hasty
retreat from the northern territory as
the survivors of the disastrous attack
that history remembers as Pickett's
charge came fleeing back to the southern
position the general rode among the men
trying to console them and admitting
that it was all his fault
in later reflection Lee admitted that he
had simply asked too much of his men at
Gettysburg he wrote no blame can be
attached to the Army for its failure to
accomplish what was projected by me I am
alone to blame Gettysburg was Lee's
greatest wartime disappointments in its
wake he tendered his resignation to
Confederate President Jefferson Davis
writing mr. president no one is more
than myself of my inability for the
duties of my position I cannot even
accomplish what I myself desire how can
i fulfill the expectations of others in
addition I sensibly feel the growing
failure of my bodily strength this was
no idle self-pitying the Civil War in in
particular the Battle of Gettysburg
broke Lee physically there is good
evidence that just before the battle he
actually had a heart attack
still Davis refused to accept his
resignation knowing that the man was
irreplaceable following Gettysburg Lee
retreated across the Potomac never to
return to the north again the following
spring a new Yankee general came to the
field to fight Lee
his name was Ulysses Simpson grant
finally the North had found a worthy
contender for the great Confederate
General unlike many of his predecessors
grant was not covered by Lee both men
underestimated each other soon
discovering that their opponents was
different from anyone else they had ever
been up against immediately upon taking
commands grant issued the following
command stood General Meade commander of
the Army of the Potomac Lee's army will
be your objective point wherever Lee
goes there you will go also grant
relentlessly pursued Lee from the
wilderness to Spotsylvania and then to
Cold Harbor where a terrible slaughter
took place throughout the bloody
campaign and despite heavy losses Lee
gallantly led his army on may the six
1864 as his line was wavering he himself
rode to the front and demanded that his
men stand their ground on the very
dangerous circumstances after June 1864
Lee's Army of Northern Virginia had been
pushed back to the defenses of Richmond
and Petersburg effectively grants had
taken in
of the war unable to maneuver and
nowhere to go all he could do now was
wait and react as grant circling around
him active with his army besieged and
pinned down he knew that the end was in
sight
Lee's anguish while being hemmed up at
Petersburg was heightened with the news
that his home in Arlington had been
confiscated by the Union government's
having been seized for unpaid taxes it
was quickly converted into a large
soldier's cemetery orders were given for
the graves to be placed as close to the
house as possible
so that it could never be used again as
a private dwelling however the cruelest
blow well it was yet to come through the
winter of 1864 Lee's army lacked forage
rations and supplies somehow the men
managed to retain their fighting spirit
but even that was to disappear in April
of 1865 with his men at near starvation
point Lee led his bedraggled army to
Appomattox Courthouse in Virginia
following a last desperate flight from
Richmond it was there that Lee
surrendered his army and ended the civil
war the correspondence between grant and
Lee during those closing hours of the
war is enlightening on April the 7th
Grant sent the following message to Lee
general the results of the last week
must convince you of the hopelessness of
further resistance in this struggle I
regarded as my duty to shift from myself
the responsibility of any further
effusion of blood by asking of you the
surrender of the Army of Northern
Virginia very respectfully u.s. grant
Lee's reply came swiftly General Grant
though not entertaining the option you
express on the hopelessness of further
resistance on the part of the Army of
Northern Virginia I reciprocate your
desire to avoid useless effusion of
blood and therefore ask the terms you
will offer in condition of its surrender
very respectfully robert e lee on the
morning of April the 9th Lee put on his
best uniform and went to the home of
Wilmer McLean where he met General Grant
the two men contrasted sharply Lee's six
feet high and with faultless form and
dress grant's five foot seven months
platters and in a rumpled privates
uniform the terms of surrender one
expectedly generous without the mark for
punishment the Confederate Army was
allowed to go home on the provision that
they would never take up arms again
against the federal governments many
historians believed that it was a
measure of grants respectfully that he
handled the terms the way he did as he
exited the McLean House Lee was cheered
by the Confederates and saluted by the
Union troops the first officer of the
Union to remove his hat and salute Lee
was great
after the warbly became presidents of
Washington College in Lexington Virginia
during those years he also found time to
write his memoir and in it he stated the
following I did only what my duty
demanded I could have taken no other
course without dishonor and if it all
were to be done over again I should act
in precisely the same manner he
dedicated his last years to education on
September 28 1870 he went to a school
meeting on the way home he caught a cold
14 days later he died the huge funeral
service at Lexington was attended by
thousands of Americans from both the
north and the south
so I really hope you found that
biography interesting if you did please
do hit that thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday also he would you like to see
on bio graphics you can go to our
companion website by graphics org click
on the bio vote in the bar at the top
and we have a voting system set up there
so we can make the biographies that you
guys want to see and as always thank you
for watching